but first christian casares joined us
live in studio with the focus on clark
county from the u.s secretary of
education and christian how new funding
will impact students well brian we're
talking about 800 million dollars
according to congresswoman dina titus
that will be allocated to the school
district very soon now it's on top of
what gets assigned by the state and
today students got to say as to what
matters to them
the students were a little freaked out
because there was like cameras in our
face but they did well
clark high school students spent part of
their school day with u.s secretary of
education miguel cardona and
congresswoman dina titus
the visit was to get a first hand look
at how students were handling their
return to the classroom after remote
learning and a better picture of the
importance of extracurricular activities
so important now
knowing that the pandemic has robbed
students of opportunities to
engage with their peers
and develop those skills so hearing
directly from the students how important
the funding that goes to our districts
is so that these activities continue as
a group of leaders explored the campus
on arville and pennwood they dropped in
during class time and sat on lectures
later they held a discussion with the
students about their experience with
school activities but the bigger concern
was staffing shortages using american
rescue plan funds to incentivize
getting educators to stay in the
profession but also let's consider
bringing back retired teachers cardona
says a long-term solution to get more
teachers in the future was already in
the works at this high school
if you can be a teacher
first time i walked into a classroom of
high school students who are studying to
become teachers
led by a teacher that's getting them
connected to unlv
for now activities like music are
expected to be enhanced by the funding
and help bring a sense of normalcy back
teachers say from the pandemic
extracurriculars is a big thing i hope
you know budgets stay maybe even grow
the allocated funds will go into the
district and will be determined how it
will be distributed now the principal at
clark high school believes this new
round of money will bring more
opportunities for students christian
casa is live local now